[Música]
hablamos de salud en directo américa de
france 24 más romero sala ya está con
nosotros en nuestro estudio mar muy buen
día hoy precisamente es el día mundial
del alzheimer una enfermedad que afecta
a millones de personas en el mundo y que
afectará todavía más en un futuro algo
no alentador por supuesto así es el raúl
es una enfermedad que está relacionada
con el envejecimiento por supuesto
aunque no exclusivamente ahora lo
hablaremos más con nuestros asesores
científicos y que a medida que la
población mundial vaya envejeciendo va a
aquejar a cada vez más personas
actualmente las sufren unos 30 millones
de personas en el mundo actualmente pero
podrían aumentar hasta los 70 en 2030
hasta los más de 120 en 2050 suponiendo
unas cargas y además unas afectaciones
psicológicas económicas
emocionales en los tejidos comunitarios
como las familias y amigos que todavía
creo que no podemos dimensionar para
hablar de esto estamos por supuesto como
con oscar franco director del
departamento de salud pública de la
universidad de utrecht doctor muy buenos
días y gracias por acompañarnos en este
miércoles frente a este crecimiento del
alzheimer que sea para los próximos años
como estén en un mundo con millones de
personas aquejadas por esta demencia y
que deberíamos estar haciendo desde ya
para prepararnos
así es mar y el panorama no es muy
alentador hemos visto como la demencia y
grasa de mercaderes suben más en el
escalafón de las principales causas de
mortalidad y morbilidad en el mundo yo
creo que ya casi todos conocemos a un
familiar o hemos sufrido la enfermedad
directamente en un amigo vecino y yo
creo que es importante hacer algo ya
mismo que se puede hacer hasta ahora
para la prevención lo más importante es
seguir un buen estilo de vida ser
activos hacer ejercicio mantenerlos
activos también mentalmente esto es muy
importante para las personas que se van
retirando y que dejan de de mantenerse
activos de manera mental pero también
seguir una buena dieta y cuidar nuestro
sueño más allá de esto los gobiernos
pueden ayudar a planear a planificar
mantener suficientes servicios para
poder atender están estas personas que
van a desarrollar esta enfermedad y
también a invertir mucho más en
investigación acerca de esta enfermedad
doctora buena mañana los saludo y le
pregunto qué es lo que provoca el
alzheimer
si las causas de lanza generalmente son
un mar de factores que interactúan de
una manera muy compleja desde factores
genéticos medio ambientales factores del
estilo de vida se ha visto que como unas
proteínas que son de bacterias para
nuestro organismo se van acumulando
alrededor de las células cerebrales e
impiden que éstas se comuniquen de
manera adecuada también se ha visto como
la inflamación crónica puede afectar el
tejido cerebral las células cerebrales y
producir la demencia o generar o
contribuir a dentro de los factores y
también la salud vascular porque los
vasos sanguíneos llevan el oxígeno que
es tan importante para nuestras células
cerebrales para poder funcionar en
general para todo nuestro organismo
entonces hay una combinación de factores
muy compleja que todavía no se entiende
de manera completa doctor precisamente
por eso quería preguntarle si es uno de
los motivos por los cuales es tan
difícil encontrar una de tratamiento o
una prevención contra esta enfermedad no
por esa multiplicidad de factores
claro y porque no sabemos muy bien qué
es lo que causa y cómo interactúan estos
factores para causar la demencia es muy
difícil poder reclutar personas que no
tienen todavía alzhéimer pero que tienen
que estar enfermas de manera incipiente
porque generalmente cuando ya se tienen
los síntomas clínicos de la enfermedad
está muy avanzado y por otro lado el
tratamiento es muy difícil porque la
enfermedad es muy heterogénea cuando una
persona puede que sirva a otra persona
puede que no porque el alzheimer la
demencia se puede presentar de maneras
muy diferentes dentro de diferentes
personas toda esta complejidad ha
limitado la capacidad para poder
entender cómo podemos prevenir y cómo
podemos tratar la demencia gracias a ver
doctor qué vínculo se ha encontrado
entre el criticismo del alzhéimer
sí hasta hasta ahora lo que se ha visto
entre el 19 y el alzheimer es que el
hobbit 19 en primer lugar las personas
que tienen demencia de alzheimer se han
reportado un mayor riesgo de desarrollar
el código de terminar siendo
hospitalizados o de morir por kobe 19 y
en investigaciones recientes lo que se
está viendo es que también el tener 19
dentro de las personas que han
desarrollado podría aumentar el riesgo
de desarrollar demencia particularmente
el personal mayores de 85 años y en
mujeres esto se está viendo en un
estudio muy grande que ha sido publicado
recientemente unas 6 millones de
personas pero con una con un seguimiento
no mayor de un año debemos recordar que
la demencia y el alzheimer toma años
para que se pueda desarrollar y por
ahora es una asociación y no sabemos si
realmente una causa pero si podría haber
una asociación por el efecto que tiene
alcohol 19 en términos de inflamación en
términos de la salud vascular y también
porque los receptores que pueden recibir
al virus también se encuentra en el
cerebro
bueno esperemos que al menos a medida
que avance y pase tiempo desde la
pandemia vayamos ampliando este rango de
tiempo y entendiendo mejor también esos
vínculos pero por último para terminar
con una nota quizás algo más
esperanzadora quería preguntarle cuáles
son los últimos avances más destacables
que tenemos pues en la lucha contra esta
enfermedad
seguimos tratando de entender esa
reacción inmune que es posible que sea
el pilar principal de los mets de los
mecanismos que llevan a la demencia y se
ha hablado recientemente acerca de
soluciones terapias inmunes
que se ha llamado por ejemplo la vacuna
contra la demencia que es similar a el
proceso que ocurre con estas vacunas que
fueron desarrolladas contra el cob y 19
y lo que hacen es tratar de atacar esa
proteína en la respuesta que nosotros
tenemos de manera inmune contra esa
proteína que se acumula en el cerebro
estos tratamientos todavía se están
desarrollando hace poco se aprobó un
tratamiento en los eeuu que puede que
ayude pero por ahora no tenemos ningún
tratamiento que tenga que ser realmente
una terapia contundente para el
tratamiento para la prevención de la de
mes y todavía falta mucho más
investigar y desarrollarlo pero creo que
se va por unas buenas habilidades de
investigación hasta ahora bueno por lo
menos gracias doctor por toda la
información sobre este tema tan
importante por supuesto también gracias
marx por liderar este tema el día de hoy
nosotros continuamos y damos entonces
pasó a nuestro